one of the most sinister.
They are characters in the Greek tragedy that
has been the Trump presidency is without a
doubt Donald Trump's press secretary, Kayleigh
McEnany, who also plays a dual role on television,
where sometimes she's not White House press
secretary, but instead she's merely a campaign
adviser for Donald Trump's presidential campaign.
Yesterday, I played clips for you of Kaili
on Fox News Monday night saying things about
voter fraud as a campaign adviser.
And then Tuesday morning, I mean, we're talking
12 hours, 11 hours later, maybe even on a
different fox, a Fox show, Fox and Friends
saying when asked about those claims, oh,
you've got to talk to the campaign about that,
because today I'm here as White House press
secretary.
How convenient.
Well, it's this completely Kafkaesque situation
that they've created.
It's mimetic, quite frankly.
And here is Kaili once again last night on
Sean Hannity's program, holding up now, I
guess these are ballots.
Previously she's held up reams of paper.
Sometimes she'll hold up a book or a three
ring binder.
And this time it's a ballot or a paper with
a lot of Sharpie circles on it.
And there's there's something particularly
ironic about this one.
Take a look like this, where they actually
list out all of the circles are different
ballot numbers.
They've written the specific ballot number
down that was dated January 1st.
Nineteen hundred for someone who didn't.
So the absolute hilarity is that now, without
any sensible legal argument left to make,
with no credible path to overturning the results
in even a single state, never mind the multiple
states they would need to overturn for for
Donald Trump to win on the basis of nonexistent
voter fraud.
Now she is relegated to talking about what
are essentially confusing layouts on pieces
of paper.
And those who have been following politics
for some time may remember the irony of this,
because back in the year 2000, the Florida
results were the question with hanging chads
and these butterfly ballots where the candidate's
name was on one side and there would be an
arrow pointing to the other side.
And it was unclear, OK, that was when Republicans
didn't want to do a recount.
That was when Republicans didn't want to really
look closely and ascertain what was the intention
of this voter in filling out this ballot.
They said, no, no, no, stop the recount.
Secretary of State Katherine, Florida Secretary
of State Katherine Harris getting involved.
The Supreme Court getting involved now after
all of their other arguments have failed and
been dismissed by courts as having no merit.
Kayleigh McEnany is relegated to saying the
layout is confusing.
There's stuff all over the page.
Look, I've circled it with a Sharpie.
They're pathetic.
Caylee continues with her various pieces of
paper.
Check it out.
Exactly.
There's no prize.
I mean, this is one county here, one county
where you have literally hundreds of pages
in one county in Wayne County, Detroit, all
across the country.
This is I tweeted about this.
This is the Gish Gallop in paper form.
That's what this has been from Kayleigh McEnany
and others who just hold up papers.
Gosh, this is actually this may be instructive
to some.
Gish Gallop is a debate term, OK?
And what it means is when a debater tries
to overwhelm their opponent just by making
lots of arguments, even if the arguments are
bogus.
Right.
You make many arguments.
It's quantity over quality.
You make a lot of arguments in a debate without
regard for the accuracy or the strength of
the arguments.
That's called the Gish Gallop.
This is Gish Gallop by paper using an excessive
number of pieces of paper to make an argument
based on the idea that you have so many pieces
of paper with no regard to the accuracy or
strength or validity or relevance of any of
those pieces of paper.
And that's exactly what we've seen.
We've seen some of these pieces of paper say
that the poll workers didn't like how they
were treated, that somebody was rude to them.
We've seen these pieces of paper refer to
towns that aren't even in the states where
they claim to be indicating there was voter
fraud.
So, for example, there was I'm trying to remember
now there was a filing made in either Pennsylvania
or Georgia which said, look at the fraud in
Michigan in these five towns.
And none of those five towns were in Michigan.
The five towns were in Minnesota.
So it's Gish Gallop by paper.
And then here's just one more where Caylee
again pulls out this term.
She created an electoral epidemic, which is
it should be seen as a joke anyway.
Take a look day pandemic and created an electoral
epidemic.
But we are fighting a new lawsuit today in
Wisconsin.
Just filed three hundred sixty six pages detailing
how Wisconsin law was violated.
So these people are well, listen, I mean,
if the lawsuit is three hundred and sixty
six pages, it must be substance substantive.
Right.
And every time I hear that phrase electoral
epidemic, I think, yes, it was an epidemic
of people voting in record numbers.
More people than ever before decided to go
and vote.
That's the epidemic, by the way.
Can you believe it's already been a month
since the election?
It's stunning how time is flying.
And the good news of that is Trump will be
gone from
the White House.
Before you know it